beast et solitaire vous enviez les
couples qui s'aiment mais vous hésitez à
vous jeter à l'eau de peur d'être
éconduits timide de tous les pays
réjouissez-vous le bip bip de l'amour
est arrivé c'est le plat chine
ce que vous entendez là ce n'est pas le
bruit d'une ambulance et le bruit qu
aimer l'oeuf la chine alors l'oeuf la
chine je vous lis ce qui est écrit sur
la notice tu sais la drague électronique
ça permet de faire plein de rencontres
simple et compact et c'est une petite
boîte de la taille d'un paquet de
cigarettes ça sport sur soi n'importe
quand n'importe où et quand vous croisez
un autre ou une autre processeur de
flashing ça émet un bip sonore autrement
dit le plat chine ça permet de faire des
tas de rendre ainsi plus de risques de
se faire traiter de sadik si vous
abordez un autre possesseur de flashing
puisque c'est le signe de l'ardent désir
de faire des rencontres
inventé par une self made woman qui a
peut être souffert ce merveilleux petit
appareil possède plusieurs fréquences
les fréquences sont des fréquences
hommes-femmes
ce sont des fréquences
homosexuel des fréquences lesbiennes et
des fréquences couples échangistes
nous avons en fait penser à tout le
monde parce qu'il ya de la place et du
coup tout le monde
voilà une attention digne d'une vraie
démocrate
mais vous même vous êtes timide non je
ne suis pas tellement timide mais je me
vois mal par exemple aller dans la rue
accrochez quelqu'un à lui demander est
ce que vous pourriez parler avec moi un
petit quart d'heure elle un petit quart
d'heure vous prendre un café avec moi
non ça je ne vois pas donc je pense que
si j'ai un saumon avec monf la chine et
si je vais dans la rue et je rencontre
quelqu'un ça c'est beaucoup plus facile
parce que je cède avance qui voudraient
rencontrer également quelqu'un mac luhan
plus fort que gutenberg et ses petites
annonces ça se discute d'abord il y a
peu de plats chine sur le marché
aussi vous risquez de faire de nombreux
kilomètres avant de rencontrer l'âme
soeur détentrice de la boîte noire
similaire
et puis ça coûte 950 francs enfin vous
pouvez vous tromper de fréquences en
manipulant l'appareil est alors
attention aux surprises
oui bonjour souvent bonjour trois moines
étoilé pas tous avoir écouté non non non
vraiment mais fait surtout attention à
l'état de vos piles
sinon vous risquez d'attendre longtemps
le signal sonore du coup de foudre
[Musique]